what's going on guys my name is David
Tomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're going to be talking about
the old Microsoft laptop 2 and also the
brand new Microsoft Surface laptop 3
that was released just a couple of days
ago and if it is a viable option to
upgrade from your old laptop I say oh
it's potentially about a year if not a
little bit more older to the brand-new
product coming out in the next week or
two I know I struggle to follow
youtubers all the time where they just
list the specs and don't really give you
any graphics and visual content so I'm
gonna drop the two contents beside me
hopefully you guys are going to be able
to screenshot this or interpret it very
quickly and understand the differences
between the two options I'll try to
highlight them for you guys in the video
now besides the spec bump that you get
for the surface laptop 3 over the
surface laptop to truly what is the
difference and does it warrant the
upgrade price-wise brand new surface
laptop 2 when it came out - brand new
surface laptop 3 now it's pretty much
like the light but because the surface
laptop 2 has been replaced by the
surface laptop 3 you can actually get
the surface laptop 2 for a much much
cheaper price than the surface laptop 3
so what would possess somebody to go out
and spend the extra money on a brand new
surface laptop 3 versus a surface laptop
- so there are actually a couple points
of difference here that I think are
going to persuade people to pick the
surface 3 over the surface - if they can
afford the price bump so one key factor
here is the simple fact that the surface
laptop 3 has a USB C port whereas the
surface 2 unfortunately only has a
single USB a port now why is this
important if you haven't noticed already
all companies are slowly moving towards
the USBC trend it will start replacing
all the lightning cables all the USB
cables and all the sound cables because
you can do everything your one go it's
unfortunate that the surface laptop 3
doesn't charge through USB C that would
have been a nice addition now even
though the Microsoft Surface laptop 3
uses Microsoft proprietary charger very
similar to
that we see in the Microsoft Surface -
in actual fact you have fast-charging
available on the surface through up to
80% in under an hour
now that is phenomenal imagine you've
just woken up forgotten to charge your
laptop overnight quickly plug it in go
have a shower get ready by the time
you're ready to leave the door and go
into the rest of your day your laptop is
almost completely charged and more than
likely you're going to be able to get
through a whole day without having to
take your charger last but not least one
of the questions I got on my last
surface laptop - video versus the
MacBook Pro was the simple fact of the
architect Eero on the surface laptop -
so many people will ask me the same
question so many people were curious
about the wear and tear of the Alcantara
do you get sweaty palm marks on the
keyboard does it stain does it where is
it durable well the honest answer is yes
the Alcantara is actually super durable
and touch wood I haven't had any
problems with mine for the last year
that I've owned it
so the Alcantara is actually engineered
and manufactured quite well that it's
not something to worry about
it is in the back of everybody's mind so
the simple fact that Microsoft has come
out with the machined aluminium finish
which is available in both the 13 inch
and the 15 inch model is incredible
because it takes away the doubt from a
lot of people so what's the simple
conclusion here is it time to sell your
surface laptop - and upgrade to a
surface laptop 3 or do you stick with
the surface laptop - because it is still
an exceptional machine in its own right
well personally speaking I'm going to be
selling this surface laptop to in the
near future and upgrading to the surface
laptop 3 but a simple fact of future
proofing my devices so from my point of
view guys the surface laptop 3 is a much
superior product it's definitely
definitely worth the price upgrade if
you're looking at comparing the surface
laptop 2 and the surface laptop 3 and
have the extra money to spend if you're
a student in Australia remember guys
that microsoft offers a 10% discount on
all their surface product so make sure
you type in your student account get
not sponsored in any way and simply get
10% off you purchase that's all from me
guys thank you so much for watching if
you haven't already make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20:19 style and if you're watching this
upon release chances are we're so close
to that 1000 subscriber mark so hit the
subscribe button let's make it to 1k and
I'll see you next Monday